欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
今天台股真的叫做世界第一强
我们尾盘上涨了820点
距离历史新高
现在只差1200点了
今天的气势从何而来呢
其实有很多事情的加持
昨天晚上我们看到
辉达跟联发科攜手开了一个
记者会宣布大事情啦
辉达要投资
这个所谓联发科的可转债
高达35亿美元
而且Google也有做一些着量的投资
这当然让今天的发哥一架涨停
但意义不止如此
等一下会来跟各位观众解析
这牵涉到台湾晶片股的
十年未来大梦
是非常重要的一件事情
这也激励掉台股今天的科技股
是全面上涨的一个态势
所以今天即使雅谷的表现不理想
昨天晚上废半也有压力
我们却气势如虹
但是我们能够带领着全世界的科技继续往上冲吗
前面会不会有一些挑战跟难关呢
以及明天所谓全世界最大的半导体展
在台湾也要展开了
会带动哪些商机
等一下一件一件跟您说分明
好第一位欢迎我们的AI达人蔡明翰
太开心了看到明翰就想到
未来台湾就有十年的AI大梦继续做下去
一切就源自于昨天晚上
挥打跟联发科一起开的合体记者会
黄伦勋黄爸爸和这个
我们联发科的执行长蔡立行
一起来跟大家讲未来的蓝图
这到底对台湾整体应该发展
会有多深远的影响
等一下一件一件跟您讲
那至于9月
很多人说9月是一个美股的魔咒月
但是现在有光亮起来了
大力光今天差一点点
就要8000块钱了
带动着整体CPU
最近有很多细光子的论坛
台积电也讲
2027年细光子的渗透率会高达50%
怎么算的
等一下明汉就联发科跟大力光
带动的两大领域跟您说清楚
第二位是我们的古旗双分析师
季伟明小明同学
小明同学也要说
半导体就是我们的主场
尤其是这两天
半导体展热热闹闹
开展了各论坛
一字排开超级强
今天盤面上谁最被低估谁在涨就是设备股有人接近前高有人是营收创高位阶却很低未来的肉相当的多等一下告诉你整体看展要看什么
还有ESIC相关的
到底台湾在ESIC这个自研晶片领域IC设计
能够拿到多少的报单量
等一下小明同学算给你听哦
好第三位呢是我们的型男股神威两哥
威两哥也要提醒大家前阵子
我们听到大家要什么呢
筹资扩厂要举债压力三大对不对
No错了
我们从发个例子就知道
你今天要发行所谓的筹资
就是为了后面要有更大的股东
后面要有更大的算力
后面要有更大的产能被压低
绝对都是一个好机会
等一下帮你把整体筹资股的运作讲回来
那至于有一档先前筹资
这两天有点压力的叫做星星
星星今天没有锁住了
甚至盘中一度要拉到平盘
危机是不是正式解除
等一下吴良哥跟您说
但是如果着眼在刚刚讲
筹资为了全球的算力
大家都在抢
有没有什么样的商品
一档全部打包
全球算力
等一下也帮您做介绍
好 首先有请米汉哥
好 今天来的正式时候
昨天晚上出大事了
这个大事是对台湾很开心
对于美股还好
可见得我们对半导体
或是IC这件事情的反应
是极大的
就是挥达买了发哥
35億美元的可轉債
並且兩人構築了
台灣晶片十年的未來大夢
等一下來幫大家解釋
9月好像美股的狀況
通常不是太好
但是光來了
台積電講說
2027年的矽光子滲透率50%
到底該怎麼買
好 應該這樣講
剛剛趙華提到
今天台灣等於是世界第一強
那重點就是因為揮打
然後投資發歌
然後台灣今天重點在十年大夢
就代表了可能短時間數字還進不來
所以大家可以知道
後面的架構大概長什麼樣子
我們先講一下這個輝達
為什麼要投資這個聯發科
那這個重點呢
就39億美元
那應該說佔了整個所謂的
佔比接近九成左右
那記得它的轉換價
就是大概4500
對 然後呢
還有一個重點
除了輝達之外
就是這個TPU的這個母公司
就是Apple的一個部分
他也有認購
但比例相對來講並不高
那公司有提到他這些未來的一些購料的需求鎖定先進製程 先進封裝還有相對需要的AI原物料應該就是未來
他拿這筆錢的一個重心
回過頭來為什麼
回答要這個投資聯發科
簡單的一個總結
就是不希望聯發科被
這個客製化晶片
ASIC那邊陣營的人給拉走
給搶走 對
然後因為就是防禦戰嘛
他就是要反制這些所謂雲端業者
自研晶片
那他要的是什麼
希望聯發科未來走他們的
等於說走輝達的架構
像NV-Link希望都走輝達的架構
就在設計上可以一起綁定
那這塊呢
聯發科的部分來講
當然OK 反正
這個目前來講
輝達的這個規格
就是一個最大的一個市場
另外一個就是產能戰
其實現在比較重要
就是台積電的產能
現在全球所有晶片都在瓜分他
那輝達該拿的也拿的
可是他應該這樣
他拿夠了之外
應該這樣他也沒拿夠
最起碼他能拿的都拿到了
可是他現在不想要
其他的產能被其他的雲專業者拿走
所以當然如果聯發科去排隊
你缺錢沒錢排隊
我出錢去排隊
不要讓他們拿走
那相對來講
當然聯發科這樣當然是好
因為他現在有產能
能夠拿到台積電產能
就是一個重要的關鍵
它就是王者
所以另外呢
就是資本站
各取所需
另外回答的部分
進可攻退可守
先放在可轉載
它有固定的利息
未來股價漲了
它又可以轉換
所以幾乎就是穩穩不賠
聯發科的部分
靠著這一段呢
合作的關係
還可以拿到比較低成本的
這個所謂的資金
所以雙面來講
都是賺的
我們再講一下
為什麼聯發科
可以這個獲得輝達的相挺
其實比較重要的關鍵
我常常講整個
所謂電子的產品線就像這樣
一開始你公司裡面要有產品的一個設計
然後呢自己
去做市產的動作
你要產品做出來自己都覺得
啊對
這個就是市場要的
等到確認之後呢
再交給客戶下去做驗證
客戶看一看說這個東西不錯
對我未來營運很有幫助
他就會取得訂單
然後訂單再要找到
這個所謂代工的部分下去量產
最後交給客戶就營收任列
他有這個一定的這個六個步驟
那我就常講這個步驟你現在位處在哪裡就很重要因為你只要越往左邊你的變數就會越大最後要認定營收的機率就會小得非常多
為什麼聯發科就是相對來講比較穩健
因為它不只是這個客戶業者
而且目前已經取得訂單
然後呢等著年底就可以大量出貨
對比而言喔就是聯發科算是今年
切入這個AI很重要的代表的全資股
另外一个市场关注的
就是有光的大力光
他也是要切入这个AI
这两家以前都当过台股的股王
只是现在当股王不容易了
要万元以上
但都重返荣耀
都创下历史新高
应该这样讲
他们两个有个特色
就是今年已经第三年AI
前两年业绩真的是平
两个都在智慧手机
两个都是平的
一点成长都没有
所以股价相对是落后的
然后一直到今年
大家都認為
以這個架構來講
他們已經即將要開始
實現的AI大夢
剛剛提到聯發科是TPU
大力光是FA
就是要進入CPU的部分
我個人覺得
設計它自己的部分已經完成了
所以它才在法說會講到
他們有這個產品
重點是他們現在正在試產的階段而已
上次法說就提到試產
產出來之後還要送客戶驗證
然後客戶覺得沒問題
而且中間常常知道
有時候看起來對
可能為了這個客戶
還要去修改相關的製程
所以兩個應該說架構對共通點
就是以前的所謂產業的王者
現在從落後了兩到三年
現在要跨入AI了
但是故事其實還
憑良心講有蠻明顯的落差
好 故事的進展雷同
以前從智慧型手機
現在都踏進AI了
但這個要成真
就是營收要進來
感覺上明年就很有機會發哥
大力光可能他自己有講
2028年才會有相關的
營收大幅的進來
所以這個進程不同
但發哥受到揮答的肯定
世界在跟我們搶人了
這個發哥陣營
揮答陣營跟所謂的ASIC陣營
都要聯發哥
這件事情無庸置疑
聯發哥今年股價能夠轉強
靠的其實是Google的TPU
那以這次回答
對於他營收獲利有沒有貢獻
答案是沒有
但是他只是要告訴大家就是說
其實回答已經看到
他不希望
聯發科跟他的競爭者走得太密
然後他這一邊呢
跟他一點機會都沒有
他覺得這樣是不對的事情
所以他願意掏一筆錢出來
然後告訴聯發科
其實你未來都可以跟我合作
另外呢大立光的部分
我剛剛提到
就是在講他也要切入
所以正在反應
我覺得這個對比來講
就蠻容易理解的
這一塊的大立光
其實就是聯發科的這一段
因為他的結構
就是之前都沒漲 對不對
然後股價明顯的落後
之前呢這個指數可能還是
他的股價可能當年指數
還在一兩萬點的位置
結果他幾乎都沒漲
然後現在跨入AI了
所以當時聯發科是大家已經確認
所以漲幅比較大
那他有個好處就是我們在講
當時在講到說7月就是這一段
股市在快速修正的過程當中
憑良心講我自己覺得
以聯發科的角度跌的不算多
那尤其是他現在的角度
是沒有任何數字的
但是我個人覺得跌不多
是因為大家都認為
他第四季明年那個數字
不會有太大意外
可是大力光現在正在反映這一段
可是記得一件事情
他不可能長到
2028年都長這個樣子
那他真的
那不要說七八千
七八萬可能都不夠他長
活回股王的真正報奏
所以我覺得我常常講
最後一定會類似這樣長
當然你會
他會像這個當時的聯巴克
到底會經過幾段才見頭
沒有人會知道
但是我看到見到頭部
見到頂之後
他一定會拉回整理
而且後續可能會有蠻長的時間
所以我會覺得
聯巴克跟大力光
乍看的故事有點像
但結構完全不同
目前的角度
看起來大力光比較強
但是我剛剛提到
聯巴克在這次事件的情況下
續航力也不會太長
他還是會持續震盪整理
但是如果以投資的角度
兩者我會稍微比較偏向聯發科
因為畢竟他是即將很快就有數字
這個相對來講
就時間軸線會拉比較長
那記得我剛剛講複製這個狀況
我不知道他現在到底是在他哪個位置
但後續只要上不去了開始下跌了
可能會拉出很長的整理時間
甚至會有比較大的一個拉回空間
所以大力光的操作也原則很簡單
反正他只要能漲你就買
你就追 買牆對 買牆他如果修正來講就不要向下攤平因為我擔心他整理的時間會很長好 但是不管發哥或是大力光或是今天整體台股的表現
都被激勵到
就是因為我們這一個台股
的AI純度非常高
是 應該說
畢竟大家來
今天要揮打都來搶親了
雖然說沒有
真正給什麼訂單
我常常覺得訂單才是真的
訂單才是聘金
對
但是整體價格
它畢竟願意投資
我覺得也是一個肯定
但是加權指數來講
我還是剛剛提到
當每次講全球特別強
就是風險
就會突然有點擔心
因為剛剛講的
這個廢半指數還在月限下
結果你準備創歷史新高
所以我還是覺得
上檔會有一定的壓力
尤其是輝達財報剛結束
我們之前也講
輝達財報後震盪是合理
但絕對不代表會轉空
所以外資最近有講到
這個雅谷持續吸睛的狀況
他有提到特別把台灣給列出來
他就有提到科技業的工業生產
持續在走高
非科技的還是相對比較弱
但他有提到
確實也有慢慢開始好轉
一點點
對 一點點
他有講到說真的也有開始好轉
另外一個架構他有提到
台灣看起來這個藍色線就是庫存
看起來庫存是不斷往上走高
對 然後你會發現生產很多
庫存一直往上走
看起來有點害怕
但他重點是
他有講到庫存對出貨比
這什麼意思
就是庫存在上方
然後出貨在下方
就居然一直往下走
這個往上
結果相除之後居然往下
代表就是下面往上的更多
其實這個是正向
代表你不用緊張
第一銷貨很快
第二就算銷貨很快
我現在還是有東西可以賣
所以整個架構來講
還是提到說
整個台股的架構
是非常的一個正向
這很很棒的一個解讀
库存虽然高
有东西可以卖
但需求非常强
所以你要多少卖给你
而且还在涨价
是 有个好处就是
大家有时候就讲嘛
就是供不应求
最后的状况都有个
这个现象就是
能卖都卖了
倒是后面没有成长
对 没有成长力道
那现在的好处就是
卖得很快没错
就居然还有办法库存
表示生产
就我们刚刚前段看到的
生产的速度很快
当然回过头来
就是细光值的部分
其实我们之前也提过几次
永遠都講矽光子夢很大
但是個股絕對不要因為矽光子就代表每一檔個股都行矽光值的特色就是基本面落差非常大這是我自己的概念我們講累積的部分
當然我永遠也講
就是在這個聯亞的部分
對 年增長好
營收 累積營收都非常的
誇張數字
所以沒有太大的問題
另外呢
這個所謂PA相關的族群
有累積
表現我覺得還算是正向
世邦因為交換器的個股
其實他也是今年
獲利年增率高
營收表現非常亮眼
這是標準的AI族群
覺得沒問題
剛剛提到大力光
到現在其實都沒有明顯的增長
他就是跟之前發各樣
其實是沒有成長的
對 沒有明顯的增長
但是我剛剛提到
大家是買未來的一個夢
我不斷強調
不是不能買
但是不要被市場的這個
所謂的訊息一直告訴你
哇 這檔以後會有多厲害
然後呢這個追也不知道是什麼原因
重點是下來也不知道要跑
然後最後等了很久
卡在那邊的時候
才來問說到底發生什麼事情
我覺得這是應該這樣講
投資的時候還是要留意風險
個股的部分我們之前來有講到聯亞
只是目前確實這一段一講完
稍微乖離率有點高
可以稍微等一下下
上禮拜才降就漲了15%
對 然後我們再來就講啊
剛剛提到就是
如果照對比一定是聯亞好
再來是全新
結果全新也已經創高
而且這兩天幾乎都拉漲停
所以最後我只好推薦一個
相對對比而言最落後
因為之前真的修正幅度很大
近期高點在這裡
對 因為之前真的也漲很多
後來發現
它真正AI的純度沒那麼高
才有這麼大的修正
那目前來講就是位階低
所以有機會
我個人覺得有機會補漲
但這個比較偏向短線
那剛剛提到
智邦就是標準AI股
整理這麼久了
甚至還給你破底 嚇死你
然後整理稍微有轉強
但是趨勢還沒翻轉
我建議大家就操作來講
一定用長線的角度分批布局
智邦其實也是蠻有同志會問的
可是大家不要忘記
智邦也是從非常低價
漲到變成2000多塊
所以現在的話
因為業績很好
所以他看來有被低估的狀況
是 應該說拉長時間來講
之前漲很多
以現在的角度
業績面還在創高
可是股價一直沒辦法
突破之前的高點
代表未來還是會有機會
反差公道
好 這邊非常謝謝敏翰謝謝好 敏翰還是要提醒大家今天氣氛很好要是今今天氣氛不好他就會講得很慷慨激昂囉就是因為今天氣氛不好反而要給一點提醒
優點自然是聯發科
現在大家都搶著要
輝達要 谷歌也要
各陣營都要我們的發歌
但是今年是看不到
很明顯成長的要到明後年囉
而大力光俠帶著
整體CPU的氣勢往上走
這個族群氣勢現在非常重要
因為本益比都拉到超級高
聯亞帶頭
那大家觀察一下
全新跟穩帽會不會繼續跟
自己要留意一下操作的風險
但是在強勁的基本面支持下
AI到明後年
甚至未來十年是不用擔心的
這件事情倒是可以值得背書一下
好 廣告回來
小明同學要上場了
一樣這兩天
大家最注意的就是
地表最強的半導體戰也在台灣
還有加上所謂的細光子論壇
種種的論壇
來幫大家講設備股今天動囉
IC設計有非常多的猛將在後頭
現在很多爸媽會幫小朋友存股
而且是一出生就去買護國神山台積電
那蔚朗老師
如果我每個月定期訂額扣一萬塊的話
當小朋友18歲的時候可以存到多少錢
佑達我跟你說
以年化報酬力8%股算
孩子18年總共投入216萬元
富利累積之後
等到成年直接就衝破了480萬
台積電是靠技術富利領先全球
而孩子的成長發育期
其實也是一種富利
而且黃金成長期如果一旦錯過了
就再也買不回來了
像莊廣和堂轉大人翠滴金
由台灣第一位女眾醫師
莊熟期博士開立
有曾外孫三胞胎成長時政
男女不同的成龍成鳳配方
精準補給黃金期的營養
純台積電是幫孩子累積財富
把握黃金成長期
是在幫孩子累積未來競爭力
幫孩子存股票
更別忘了幫孩子存未來
孩子的成長不能等喔
好 雖然剛剛明漢也有講
這個半導體展中間
有可能我們會有一點點壓力
不過也正常
因為今天我們真的叫做
領先全世界的大漲
吐回去一點點沒關係
重點是看展看門道
今天就有人動啦
我們一直都覺得
設備股接單滿滿的
怎麼還沒輪到它
看來就是蓄勢待發
有人甚至接近前高
今天你帶來的是
營收有創高 位階還很低的
還有延續著剛剛聯發科的話題
ESIC要爆單了
我們IC設計族群還有哪些猛將
今天講的這兩個
都是我非常喜歡的產業
是不是 喜歡到不行
所以我要來跟大家分享
當然啦 我們在看半導體展的時候
我們還是要先搞清楚
台積電在未來幾年
它的先進製程的藍圖怎麼去做配置
我們今天這一邊呢
基本上把未來大概三到四年的
都已經包起來了
我們現在的這個地方
2奈米嘛
2025年就開始量產
可是大家要知道
台積電的製程節點
不是說2奈米結束以後
然後就往下一步去推
它會針對2奈米去做改良
所以我們看到2026年今年有所謂的N2U跟N2P
N2P這個東西啊
它就是一個我們說的通用型的強化
那N2U是什麼呢
就是我們在成熟的平台上面呢
再把它做得更好更有效率
到了2027年明年N2X
這個是針對什麼
針對HPC高效能運算的晶片
好那我們除了這些2奈米以外呢
我們接下來還要往A16甚至往A14去走
因為其實這裡還有一個A16啦
但A16它是第一代導入所謂的金貝供電
就是我们看到这个Super Power Rail
它是第一代
到了A12以后呢
会变成第二代
这个是2028年量产
2029年量产
2030年开始量产
这也就代表的是台积电
已经针对未来四年的制程的那个road map
已经先帮大家写好
所以台积电能不能再涨四年呢
我们就要看这些制程
何不可以持续的在全球去做领先
一定可以的
一定是可以的啦
这个我是蛮有信心的
当然我们针对的不同的制程里面的话呢
这个是在台积电他们在近期有很多的论坛
我們先把其中的這個藍圖呢
拉出來這是大家最在意的
可是在論壇裡面呢
也有提到所謂的意志整合
我覺得大家常常聽到這個詞
可是又有一點點陌生
這詞聽起來就很難懂
很難懂
請你用一個白話文翻譯舉弱
白話文來講的話就是呢
不同大小的積木
你要把它拼在同一塊拼圖上面這樣子
大概是這樣子啦
原因是因為我們知道現在的這個地方
中間會有一塊晶片
旁邊要放很多的HBM嘛
對不對要放很多HBM
甚至你還會有所謂的電源管理IC
你有不同的IC
可是這些IC它的製程可能不一樣啊
這塊晶片用2奈米
那你這個地方用的是Dram的製程
你PMIC可能用成熟製程就可以
我要把不同的製程全部拼到一塊基板上面
這個叫做所謂的抑制整合
大概就是這樣
那現在2025年做的COVAX呢
是5.5倍的光照尺寸
可是你隨著現在的晶片
它越做越大
它要整合的東西越來越多
到了2029年甚至要做到14倍的光照尺寸這是一個造證計畫就對了越造越密而且精度越來越高對啊这个东西对于设备来讲的话对于设备厂一定是一个长期的大力多
而我们现在的摩尔定律
大家会想说
我们不是已经靠这个
所谓的晶片越做越小
而是你要去搭配
这个先进制程
晶片越做越小
背面的供电
晶片供电
HBM
然后做所谓的晶片
3D的去做堆叠
然后CoAX去做封装
还有甚至连细光子的光电整合
這些把它包成一個系統呢
會形成所謂的新的摩爾定律
它變成是一個系統
而不是一顆晶片來看
所以我們看到了你不同的技術
它其實要對應到的
就是不同的設備廠
我覺得全民的科技知識
在這兩三年
因為AI的發展
應該都有大幅的提升
可能是股民對於科技的發展
有知識大幅的提升
以前我們知道成熟製程先進製程
現在還有這麼多名詞
一支整合啊
金貝供電都要了解
特別是我覺得
有做股票的投資朋友
那個腦袋不會鈍化啦
要學新的東西
好 那我们今天其实要掌握的就是
因为设备股今天G2C联盟
很多都已经喷出去了
那现在我们要关注的是
营收已经创历史新高
但是未接还没有这么高的公司
有没有还真的有
所以我们从营收来去帮大家做挑选
这边我们去做排列的方式
我们先从锁定率
也就是从筹码
这我已经是老朋友了
就是主力券商买的这个股票的集中度
这边的话就同样的
我们从基本面
从筹码面来去帮大家做挑选
我们还是先看一下这个选股逻辑
因为我们前面讲过阳城
因为这两个礼拜前讲的阳城
就涨了17%
还在创历史新高
然后你这边的话讲说
感觉股价创新高
但是外资才刚开始买
确实大户还在增加
这个就是发哥
其实你对发哥一直不离不弃
给你一个赞
等到回公道了
因为8月25号才刚讲
他就得到这个大喜讯了
我觉得在这里的话
其实我们挑选的逻辑
就是你从基本面出发
因为其他的公司
他們也一定會像聯發科
他為什麼會被揮答入股
一定是因為揮答
認為他這間公司有價值
才願意買他的可轉値
不能被別人搶走
所以買好公司的好處就是呢
其他強的公司會往他身上靠
所以我認為陽城其實股價
在今天他一樣創了一個高點
雖然留黑K
但是只要股價能創高
代表設備還沒走完
那剛剛明漢哥也講完了
聯發科其實在這裡的話
IC設計ASIC的十年大夢
這個是值得期待的
我還是蠻看好的
我們以設備來講的話
第一間先看6187的萬潤快接近這個1490的前高了對 快接近前高那為什麼會在這裡看第一個是因為它形態這裡我會把它視為是一個很大的晚行底這麼大 非常大
它這邊的底部是有打出來
我們從上一次萬潤的法說會
它有提到產能利用率
現在是維持高檔
訂單的能見度是延伸到
2027年的第二季
但不要忘記
這個是現在它的在手訂單
如果後面還有新的訂單進來
這個數字會再一直往後延伸
另外萬潤的話
因為過去從單機的設備
變成他要做整合
我要怎麼樣做一站式的
從貼合點膠一直到後面的封裝
我能做的我全部一次提供
所以專案價值會提升
更重要的是
細光子的自動光偶合機呢
萬潤也有相關的設備
因此數字是真的開得出來
以股價的型態來講
距離前高一步之遙
碗形底打好
大戶的籌碼在這邊增加
那對我來講啦
其實這邊要去創高
我認為其實非常容易
是 非常容易
所以設備長裡面
萬潤在這裡
我們當成是一個龍頭的觀察
一旦它能夠創高
其他的設備應該也有機會落後補漲
所以我們第二間公司
我就會看4949的有成精密
好 這家其實營收很好
但是股災的時候可以跌到50幾塊
真是不可思議
我是覺得很委屈啦
但是形態上它又轉強喔
因為第一個它已經站上了
所有的短中長期均線
那再來第二個的話
我們講的是它在做的是
所謂的離子植入跟MOCVD設備裡面的
特殊材料零組件
這個MOCVD是什麼
很多的光通訊啊
大家看到全新啊
聯亞他們在做的
其實製程就是MOCVD
所以這些設備只要持續去做使用
裡面的耗材一定要更換
因此有成精密為什麼會看他
因為他的主要客戶就有台積電
聯電美光格羅芳德跟英飛林
全部都是他的客戶
這個時候他的營收數字
上半年獲利EPS2.67
7月年增將近翻倍
這個是創35個月以來的新高
今年法人預估的EPS6塊
可是我們看到他的股價卻只有多少
81.7 換算下來的話
等於是你本益比不到13倍
我會覺得以設備股來講
這個確實有一點委屈
那我們看到的大戶持股
也真的有在增加
而且近期外資在這一個月
8月份是偷偷的在佈局
所以股價今天這一根長紅K
去做表態站上了季線
它等於是整個心態
對我來講叫做轉多
那量能也真的有在微微的放大
就稍微放大一點
那我認為在這個地方
因為距離前高1.1.2
還真的是有一段距離
那我們當純的去參考今年6塊錢的EPS
那如果今天設備能夠給到20倍的本益比的話其實等於是上方我覺得補漲的空間還是蠻值得期待好 當然這個可能也受限於它是資金上面比較沒有發現到的
不是那種領頭羊指標股啦
有待發掘的寶藏
這個後面就慢慢我們觀察嘛
且戰且走
那當然我們再講到聯發科的話
ASIC這一塊
也是我在年初的時候有強調過
今年一定要看的就是這四個字
ASIC
現在ASIC的話
它的成長速度事實上是超越GPU
從ASIC目前來講的話呢
你看2026年的預估
差不多一拜一拜
現在我看到的ASIC年增的速度呢
甚至還會超越所謂的GPU
所以為什麼ASIC會在這邊大幅度的成長
最主要是過去我們一直希望的是
模型的推這個訓練的能力
可是當你模型訓練好了以後呢
大家用AI的人越來越多
我需要的是推論速度的增加
因此這一些CSP大廠
他們採購的結構也會出現變化
2025年呢
可能你的AI ASIC的部分呢
只占了你說採購金額25%到30%
可是到了現在
我模型都訓練的差不多啦
我現在要提供的就是
我的客戶他需要什麼服務
我就針對這個服務去設計晶片
所以ASIC的部分已經占到了
40到50%的採購的這樣的資源
因此在未來只要能夠打入ASIC供應鏈的
應該基本上營收數字
都可以看到未來好幾年
那我們以技術進化來講的話
因為Google的TPU
或者是AWS的Trainment
在今年都已經開始去做2奈米的頭片跟流片
所以隨著下一代ASIC的產品
他們要用到的門檻提高
又切回去我們前面講的設備
另一方面軟體的部分
在IC設計也會是台灣在下一步
我認為2027年會是一個大放異彩的一年
因為今年營收數字像發哥也沒有開出來
可是明年會大幅成長
好 但是發哥被肯定
回答是有加持的
因為就是不要他被那些ASIC廠商綁走
沒錯
顯見他是絕對有能力的
但是你說台灣的ASEC廠商雖然多
但誰是有能力的
可能我們要鑑定一下
對 因為我們講到了 IC設計很多
可是你真的能夠切到AI
或者是 ASIC專案的
這個要篩選一下
當然第一個我們這邊去做排列的
我呢其實會從這個
所謂的外本筆去看一下
原因是因為今天
我是覺得驚恐亮燈
是有一點蠻讓我意外的
驅動IC 對
因為它是做驅動IC
而且以前是元泰電子紙那條供應鏈
純度其實很高
可是它跟 ASIC
好像就沒有那麼有關
那我們一樣先把它選出來
因為它的外本比高達7.44
什麼是外本比
就是在最近這60個交易日
外資買了這間公司股本多少
這間公司有7%
都被外資在這60平台
那是相當多
非常高
這個數字其實高到我很少看到
再加上我覺得今天會漲停
也是因為一方面
它本益比確實是偏低啦
那我們當然在這邊看到的
還有大戶的增持
還有外本比
我覺得5.91像愛普
我們等一下也可以來聊一下
天玉同樣是做驅動IC
金鴻今天漲停
我們通常會直覺聯想到天玉
那這些外本比都很高
其他的外本比雖然不高
可是一樣的
他們的營收都創了
近12個月以來的新高
至少我們從營收的數字來講
基本面沒有太大的疑慮
所以我會從本益比跟外本比去做挑選
那在這裡我們挑到的第一間
就是6531的愛普
IP相關的肯定也是Ethic的受惠股
是的 創意啦 世新愛普
而且我們以愛普來講的話
他是台灣或者是全球少數
真的能夠去做所謂細電容
IP設計的公司
這個是他非常強大的利基點
因此我們可以看到包含像外資
在近期這兩個禮拜算是買超的
數量算多的
而且他們從7月底是一路買
現階段來講這些ASIC的記憶體需求
就是愛普在IP這邊能夠提供的服務
所以營收數字有沒有開出來
第二季營收年增78%
7月份的營收年增甚至來到了144%
所以上半年的EPS數字已經開出來
雖然你用本益比看還是很貴
可是我會認為創意如果能夠漲到右上角
沒有道理愛普不去挑戰前高
所以我們在這裡技術型態已經完成了以後
而我認為愛普確實是有機會
有機會往前面的高點去做挑戰
那再來第二間公司的話呢
我們就會去看這一個剛剛講到的
4961的天玉
我們有討論一下真的嗎
因為你說看金鴻想到天玉也對啊
都是驅動IC的廠商
但是要有能力做ESIC喔
這邊的話我會去看天玉的原因是
因為天玉我們講電子子的時候
它純度沒有金鴻高
可是另一方面
它確實有切入所謂的客製化晶片
這一塊就是ESIC的基礎
那現在的邊緣AI呢
主要是用在生物辨識
機器人跟工業裝置
那我認為天運的好處是什麼
我們剛才前面講到像金銅會漲停
就是他本益比低 可能低估
然後外資拚命買
那現在我們看一下天運有沒有外資拚命買
其實外資買了一次 兩次 三次 四次
外資是一路買上來
所以他的外本比一樣高達3.35
這個數字是高的
那我們以上半年的EPS5塊錢
反人預估今年的EPS11塊
這個並沒有高估
所以你看他現在的股價167換算下來本益比只有15倍不到形態上跟金鴻也蠻像的就是他們前面都在一個區間震盪整理可是金鴻今天已經向上突破創了一個波段高
那我就會認為
市場可能是沒有發現天玉
而且天玉是真的有去切入ESIC晶片
所以從我的角度來講的話
大戶是一路的買上來
籌碼非常集中
外資在這邊也沒有開始落跑
所以我們現在這邊進場
其實你成本跟外資是差不多的
搭外資的順風車
那如果後面天玉真的在一個
本益比相對比較低
又能夠順利切入
客製化晶片ASIC的話
它的股價估值就不會
只有用15倍去做計算
那至於要用20倍還是25倍
就留給大家做一個想像的空間
好 當然這個族群是有大哥的
就是聯勇
對 希望聯勇如果
其實聯勇股價也不弱
也不弱 而且天玉是鴻海集團的
也是家大業大
好 這邊的話非常謝謝
小明同學幫我們挖寶藏
謝謝
好 小明同學講了兩個族群
一个是设备
其实设备我们也是长期追踪
为什么呢
因为在手订单就是满
讲到2027年可能都算客气的
有人到2029年都已经排了
在这样的情况下
大部分设备股都角出
非常亮眼的营收增长
以及满满的未来的展望
可是有的股价却相对的低
在这一次的半导体展
非常有机会带领设备股
继续往上冲
回到合理评价
另外从发哥看到我们的IT设计
刚也讲了
真的还不是每一家都能够
接到ESIC的订单
但是我们把有可能性
以及位阶相对低
也是一样营收往上走
而且外资在大买的
列给大家看
请您做一下参考了
好广告回来
微凉要上场了
现在全世界
全世界最缺的就是算力
大家都在抢
还有就是会帮您
分析一个特殊的现象
为什么台场
要一直筹资扩厂呢
为什么引进大股东呢
也是在拼算力
总归这样的事情
要如何投资
等一下教您一档包牌
好 我們最近都說
揮答叫做全世界的AI央行
但是前一陣子只要一聽到
要借錢啦 要擴產啦
就直接跟你殺下去
其實這是一個錯誤的想法喔
好 所以這邊的話
要來請教微量囉
像發哥啊 星星
其實之前都有籌資計畫
很奇怪耶
大家聽到我們的台灣廠商籌資
明明就是為了要搶
全世界的算利財
卻統統給他先負面評價
覺得會擴充資本額
會稀釋獲利
但發哥告訴你不會 我引進大咖星星要不是有這兩天的事件其實之前也創下歷史新高等一下會教大家新興現在怎麼看但是總體而言
籌資股就代表
未來有潛力是最甜的
以及算力全球在搶
用一檔就可以包牌了
全球AI的商機真的非常大
所以龍頭大廠互相
也是在強強結盟
糾團打群架
那打群架當然就是因為
想要卡位未來的算力商機
基本上因為台積電有提到
未来几年
每年AI的基础设施
都会暴增五倍
五倍啊
五倍五倍五倍
这样跳升上去
所以从2022年到现在为止
全球的AI推论的Token
已经是增加了500倍
所以这次连发科
这个重磅的发债的讯息
我觉得我们就看到
它其实就真的叫做
左右逢源
左勇右报
这个有辉达
也有Google
两大咖都来做投资
但是其实说到很多
这些大厂的投资动作
大家有没有发现
怎么样
其实透过不同的筹资管道
好像对于股价的影响
它的股价表现的模式
明显的不一样
先讲像发哥
这一次因为他是发海外可转债
当然也有很多的国内公司
他们是在国内发行
国内的CB可转债
那无论如何
通常来说发可转债
它会比较偏向于是在
股价相对低档的时候
先压低去做定价
那第一点将来
如果股价冲上去了
比较有利可图
那就算去执行了转换权利
把债券换成股票
通常对股本所造成的膨胀
稀释效果比较有限
以这次联发科来说
就算它的ECB全速转换
大概只会膨胀股本1.67%
另外刚刚赵华问到
像星星前阵子也有增资
他其实发的是GDR全球存托平证
当然也有很多公司是在国内
直接就是办理现金增资
那现金增资对于公司的角度来讲
它希望筹资极大化
因为我定好了一定的发行的
新的股本的章数
那所以如果要筹资极大化
它就会希望把价格拉高
或者是利用那种
可能十年一遇的商机
股价已经冲高了
来到历史高点的时候
再来办现金增资
所以大家对于现金增资或GDR
会比较再更敏锐一点
会怕说会不会这里就是
以后回头来看相对的高点
那它對於股本的膨脹的這種壓力其實也會更大 也會比較大對 那回到剛才講的可轉債去激勵股价有四个重要时间点第一个就是可转债定价之后因为我刚才讲定价钱会压抑
那定价之后呢
那一只手就移开了嘛
是
对 第二个就是可转债或ECB
正式挂牌之后
第三个
因为它挂牌要三个月以后
才能够开始进入到转换时期
所以这也是一个观察的重要时间点
最后一个呢
像我们国内可转债通常是三年
那联發客這支ECB是五年到期
到期之前如果還有一些債券
還沒有轉換的話
通常也會吹油門
去讓股價衝過轉換價格
所以大致上我們從這個
所發行的可轉載公司來看
我大概只把七八月以來
比較有指標性的公司
整理在這張表格
大家可以去觀察一下
不是只看它今天漲跌幅如何
而是你要去看
它前面從CB挂牌之後
是不是普遍來講
都有一段涨势
就符合我刚才讲的
关键时间点之一
那另外我们可以看到
公司的企图星
你如果按照它
CB发行的规模
去对应它的股本来看
你会发现
简单举例来讲
万润最近也蛮强的
对啊
股本不到10亿
它CB发了30亿
是
那这个代表就是
因为你要上场打群架
是
你需要让自己更强壮
要有足够的养分
也就是资金
是
所以这个大概也是可以参考
那这边相对来看的话
我认为像一拳
因为它的转换价格是在256
那目前其实它的股票试降
稍微只有略高于此
高过一点点
所以我们来看一下
它的一个走势来讲的话
就是最近慢慢垫高
先站上月线再站上季线
然后投信明显的连续买超
那你不要看说
过去几个月它从300多块
好像做了一个下行修正
可是我觉得这真的有点委屈
因为股价虽然修正
但大家很明显看到
营收是在暴冲的
然后甚至呢
更长期来讲
决定它的获利表现的
所谓的获利四律指标
毛利率 营益率
税前税后净利率
获利的四律指标
其实整个趋势都是在往上的
四律四升
对 所以我觉得这个可以沿着呢
近期的均线
去留意它接下来的表现
再来就是我们来看一下
今天呢 星星
没有在第二根了
没有耶
而且还一度往平盘探去
爆量了
可是投信是卖
投信卖
那外资买
外资买了4200多张
所以现在看起来呢
我觉得最坏的已经过去
现在大家最关心就是
新天的卖出会不会
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕